tu as well coup tranquille tranquille
tranquille on est bien on est presque
calif
il reste plus qu'un match à gagner
peut-être ça va quoi pour ça se passe
bien non ça se passe tranquille ou
attends je vais tu sais quoi je vais
rajouter un peu de réseaux sociaux et
tout on est parti un peu en avance dans
le sens où vous voulez faire c'est un
peu le ce qu'on envoie un abonnement
d'un an le gard le boss le way avec un
concours de pronos du coup de stylet
choquera attendre un message sur twitter
tac
il était là le truc way pour le concours
de pronos je met le lien pour ça qu'on
démarre un peu en avance en fait c'est
un faux démarrage
enfin en fait on n'est pas là ils ont
enfin on est là y mais on n'est pas en
stream friture on est on est chez nous
quoi je combats pas si le truc est là il
m'est chère ont pas mal on ne se sent
pas obligé de commenter la faille et
bomba les pièces sont en place peut dire
d'autre oui avec de la peinture on s'est
obstinée réseaux sociaux fais ce que tu
veux faire un jour tranquille là donc on
est là mon époque on est là sans être là
potes
servant pour que les gens arrivent
lancés le truc tu épouses quoi l'épousé
c'est fantastique cette expression roi
des poules à châteaulin à j'adore
l'image est sorti un petit ok bouveur
aussi tout à l'heure la diva est ok mon
jeu parce qu'elle me dit je suis ok vous
c'est un truc relou j'adore cette
expression est ok vous verser quand même
devant des villes et ça me fait marrer
non j'ai pas autre conflit n'est pas
trop dans le hockey bauer non non on a
du coup nombre soit je m'en fous c'est
pareil cette expression j'aime bien le
mot boomer en fait j'ai pas ces genres
des douleurs vous mr hockey bauer le mot
en soit me fait rire en fait ni rebondi
quoi y'a boom dedans donc forcément ok
boomer dégage ben salman al khalifa il
faut qu'on va forcément connus au québec
c'est un tel bonheur de faire à
disposition de conversation moi ça s'est
lancé
écoutons et bien je crois que les
travaux ils ont arrêté non plus ou moins
chez barry tapis d'étape
ils font des petits travaux ils sont
bien quoi non mais bon pour qui se
fanent quoi japonnais - mais est-ce que
c'est légal déjà mais est-ce que c'est
légal à ce qu'un avocat dans le chat qui
veut dire est-ce que je peux monter leur
taper sur la gueule avec une batte en
fait parce que je crois que da n'est pas
loin de l'être
je sais pas taper avec une batte je
pense celui qui à la batte a toujours
raison il règle
malheureusement j'ai pas de battre mais
moi j'avais une batte
mais mes jeux les plus de huit heures
ouais non j'avais une bonne pâte quoi
c'était bien j'avais acheté quand
j'étais aux etats-unis c'est un souvenir
tout de suite senti que ça pouvait
servir une sorte qu'ils les marteaux ça
marche aussi donc à temps et les parties
et ce con là où on en est quoi tu as mon
écran tu as tout à l'écran le tour mais
j'ai quand même pu ouvrir mon petit chat
fenêtres et de l'autre côté
voilà ni gagnes tu connais web un site a
suivi a atteint un peu regardé la série
avec les zombies là comment il s'appelle
déjà
je la regarde pourtant cette série j'ai
pas le mollah km où le vin le nom de la
série août à des zombies et à les mecs
bon ils sont là et il ya un personnage
s'appelle n'y gagnent à la fin pas à
partir de la saison 6 je pense ou 7,9 je
regardais wellwood des doigts les usa
mais franchement j'ai faim j'ai un peu
fait je regarde cette série comme
regarde d'autres séries serma technique
c'est que j'avance de quinze minutes je
regarde trois minutes à onze et quinze
minutes pour la finir en fait c'est fait
quand j'en ai marre maintenant vous
regarde bah ouais moi aussi de basses
fins jarrier tête les cinq robert serry
normalement les cinq premières saisons
normalement que ça m'a saoulé mais je
voulais quand même ça recommence a fini
c'est donc j'ai fait notamment se trouve
j'avance à fond en fait
et puis jouer un peu ce qui se passe
quoi tu vois je vous non mais à un
moment donné les séries gestion qui
commit savent plus trop quoi dire ils
ralentissent complètement le rythme en
bas vous êtes sévère beaucoup
j'en connais une maison beaucoup que
c'est la saison ouais soit l'un soit
l'autre en fait non sherbrooke le rythm
is père non mais tu dois continuer à
tomber dessus et puis c'est tout mais je
trouve une fin ou importe
oui c'est ça c'est game of thrones garde
sait très bien qu à la fin bon voilà
pour finir les comptes eut tout le monde
tu as vu à la vidéo du trop peur sur sur
la fin de game of thrones ou pas je peux
sur shebab d'être bête il explique enfin
problème de game of thrones est que
personne n'avait compris qui était le
méchant c'est pour ça que sa part être
complètement de la merde
en fait une fois que tu as compris que
c'était brennan le méchant en fait ça va
en fait c'est la corneille aux trois
yeux on sait faire à ses fins du coup
spa brennan en fait c'est la corneille
ou trois yeux qui voulait absolument
prendre le contrôle du trône et en fait
ça explique tout fait ça explique
pourquoi ce qu'ont ils manipulent tout
le monde pour qu'ils viennent tous bat
laura de la new york est complètement
débile et en fait c'est que ça rend
alors à de la nuit très fort quand même
pas si tu tout le monde qu'il avance
banon mais en fait ça fasse un abruti
non mais bon on l'a en fait il a fait
une interprétation à lui c'est parce que
les scénaristes ont voulu faire non
maintenant mais en fait il dit qu' il
sauve la série avec son interprétation
où je le dis dans la vidéo il faut
rester là de faire la série tellement
nul je sauve la série quoi il sauve la
série ouais c'est bien quoi bravo est ce
que andré qui nie les shows à jouer aux
jo au jamel jamel c'est marrant comme
ceux dossa au-dessus rapporte que meuf
s'appelle vaut déjà belle
l'un de ses parents qui ont fait un jeu
de mots le plan ode à la javel il ya
plus de pub à la télé n'ont fait
longtemps qu'on entend plus parler de
javel ou alors en plastique d'autres
ah ouais j'avais l'an passé ma mère elle
adorait la javel bah je sais pas quand
je suis arrivé en russie en fait pour du
coup tu ne sais pas trop comment faire
le ménage quoi je comprends pas mais le
limon à ma mère a misé machette de la
javel en fait bon du coup j'ai cherché
mes mecs ne connaissent pas la jav est
pas fiable
ban en voitures ornées des pastilles
justement lors de france ouest et ya un
business class et servi d ardeur et ce
qu'ils ont un autre truc que la javel un
peu similaire
bah ils ont nos cieux propre ça va
monsieur propre
il est là il passe même à la télé à fond
enfin alors que nous patrons donc
monsieur propre
non monsieur propre il passait il
passait beaucoup de temps après j'ai pu
la télé mais j'ai l'impression que quand
je vais chez quelqu'un avoir la télé il
n'y a plus de cap à monsieur propre
ben y'a plus de pub pour laver chez toi
en fait tu n'as tu tu fais tout
dégueulasse comme non bah oui bah je le
sien propre quand même fin en plus vers
des pays où il n'ya pas de genre [ __ ]
en espagne ils ont pas de sirop du cir
est une grenadine
non ça n'existe pas c'est abuser ça ben
je vois un badaud du couple est à
nouveau monté un bar à sirops en espagne
on vend en russie on ou un barrage avec
quoi les mecs boivent de la javel aux
idiots c'est un peu comme la vodka quoi
souffre
ouais ça ne leur fait rien en fait assez
ou très intéressant quoi ça nettoie bien
l'intestin
c'est bien et du coup tu as deux
nouveaux donc il manque des trucs à bas
sûrement mais bon là déjà c'est des
trucs sur ça c'est bizarre car grâce à
shawky le barjavel pour les littéraires
alors là attention donc je mets le petit
lien vers le discorde fab pour le
concours de pronos irait jusqu'à 14h
donc là mais il ya quand même un
abonnement d'un an diamant a gagné
toutes les vidéos les cours les
posologies limitée etc
ouais avec les pneus alors je suis
limité pour réussir à faire 35 nice il
joue a fait 35 morts à je me suis
qualifié mais du coup vient d'être
annoncée pas sûr que je vous le truc
mais je me suis qualifié ensuite eu à le
faire moi aussi bien je me qualifie gc
c'est dur de se qualifier franchement on
a galéré ne battra contre un ouais non
mais vraiment c'est c'est vraiment pas
évident ces sprints de problèmes street
de prélèvement trois minutes pendant
cinq minutes en 3 même d'un objet bon
chemin
enfin 33 c'est plus dur c'est à dire que
35 en cinq minutes oui enfin c'est
facile paix pouces quoi en premier ce
n'est pas si simple
en fait je crois que les premiers essais
je fais 31 32 33 après je resté bloqué
dans ces eaux là après j'en ai fait un à
34 jeter des guillemets restait cinq
secondes j'ai trouvé la réponse mais il
fallait jouer cinq coups du coup le
temps de le temps de faire le truc bas
s'était perdue jeudi jean provencher
injonction n'en faut jamais réfléchir en
fait je vous prouve qu'une clio légal a
fort mal à former coutin tranquille à
sont-ils bust les amis non mais 35,6
t'entraînes tu y arrives un bien sûr
mais du premier coup c'est chaud
franchement du premier coup c'est chaud
et en plus on ne peut pas tu ne peux pas
te on peut pas trop regarder les faire
pourquoi parce qu'en fait on peut pas
enfin c'est pas comme une partie
d'échecs où on peut pas se mettre celui
que j'ai loupé ses cavalières qu'à celui
que je vous plais cet échec échec échec
et fourchettes pour ceux qui ont regardé
tu dis de sur facebook j'avais un
cavalier échec un deuxième échec un
échec qui alliant design et celle du
cavalier machin après un échec avec la
tour et une fourchette
non mais là c'est une mousse lipschutz
vote comme une merde qui mixe il a forcé
les mêmes puzzles qui reviennent en va
non ils ont changé là ils en ont
tellement rajouter que non sont beaucoup
plus loin ouais tu en fais pendant une
semaine et tu fais les 35 easy même
situé 15 cents ah non en fait tu en
feras jamais 35e c'était 15 cents pas de
chance faut progresser mais tu
progresses ça c'est sûr mais 35 sont pas
faciles alors je pense 35 c c'était pas
au moins 2000 ça me paraît difficile
garde qui fait 25 à 25 c'est franchement
c'est déjà pas mal mais truc c'est que
le gap entre 20
5 et 30 il est énorme que les exercices
sont plus en plus urgent posture marque
un peu tu peux tomber sur un truc dur à
un moment donné en fait donc ça démarre
dans trois minutes femme un prono nul je
sais pas qui allait blanc ml beau
cultiver gagnes tu lâche l'info bah faut
toujours un il peut gagner mais on
espère en tout cas tout cas il fait les
favoris ça c'est sûr pour maintenant
mais gagner c'est pas faux mais il peut
planter d'ouverture donc ok faut viser
ce à quoi il va jouer quatre tu penses
oui oui je suis sûr aucune raison tu
fais autre chose
non mais oui enfin je suis d'accord avec
toi c'est juste et ce qu'il peut avoir
envie de 9 me surprendre de surprendre
reprend en fait si tu as besoin d'y
reprendre enfin qu'en fait du coup tu es
tu te sens mieux préparés que ton
adversaire et du coup tu utilisais
surprise pour éviter pour éviter la
prépa ou quelque chose mais elle en fait
vu que c'est lui qui s'en est mieux
préparé que son adversaire cédric in de
chercher à surprendre que l' inverse
donc tu as tu en as tu attends quoi
comme lâchez pas ou 4 5 ou karo kann
jusqu'à trente six ans dans quel état
d'esprit à airdrie kin ball dans l'état
d'esprit voit une partie n'ont pas joué
une partie jouée une partie jouée un
coup je vais vite et vous éviter bien
enfin je pense qu'il a il a tout le
répertoire de conseils non cherchez la
femme gagné une partie
se qualifier en demi-finale enfin je
sais pas quoi aller dîner aille dans un
très gros état d'esprit quoi je pense
après eux quatre ils y pensera à jouer
un coup enfin maxime 12,4 et andré kings
il se dit jouer un coup exactement
il joue la berlinoise ou pas dimitri
affable il peut jouer concarnoise juxue
réfuté c'est pas de chance mais ça a
prouvé quand même y accéder a réfuté
toute personne ne la jouent toujours qui
va laisser réfuté ça mais c'est beau
quand même les infos se flatte que ça je
fus tgv qui égalise et la gauche c'est
la fuite et j'emmerde non ils ne
connaissent absolument rien a boy ça
c'est sûr moi je sais que non non mais
je sais pas peut-être qu'ils ont peur
d'une pincée contrebas d'une con tre
prépa ou d'un truc un peu différente
c'est plus dur à tout apprendre par
coeur j'en sais rien en fait mais dans
la première faut dire qu'après caïds et
de il aurait été mieux mais l'autre
s'était planté aussi ouais bah oui non
mais en fait moi on n'a pas vu de vrais
trucs bien on nous demandait ce que ça a
porté bonheur à maxime si j'achète la
vidéo sur le pur isolé bas je crois
qu'en fait ça ça va se décider là dessus
et my halo
je crois qu'on aurait tout se joue là
dessus sur celle à acheter un d acheter
une série vidéo quoi alors t'as combien
la sur les planches au final moi je veux
ça fait trente a laissé pas mal déjà
fait à dire ça veut dire que tu vas tu
menaces de réussir oui je me sens
heureux
est-ce que je peux remettre le petit
échiquier ouais bah écoute on va voir on
va voir comment c'est à ça ça se passe
avec les grand échiquier et on verra ce
que pourquoi la question sourire sans
dortmund boivin synthèse clairement pas
dans tous nos jeux mais bien un peu
comme sa compagne française ait un
échange
ouais bah du coup comme etienne comme le
yuan
je vais bien d'autres trucs quand il ya
aubameyang
sinon le jeu vont chauffer l'eau d'heure
tong yen murs jaunes quoi salut paquito
donc trois bons en dessus bon ok les
pcistes très bien kaïs et si c'est
intéressant vous des six jouable voilà
l'autre ou moins bien fort besoin que
vous jouerez scott pilgrim connu une
baisse d'audience depuis deux chaises 24
non pas le moins du monde forgotten est
donc une hausse d'audience d'une
audience à peut-être une audience plus
très complètement non mais a pas de ça
monte petit à petit en fait suivant
suivant les boss qui veulent et les buzz
les boss d'ailleurs les buzz qui va y
avoir d'autres essences qui va je dois
me donner
c'est étrange non comme le choix côté
maxime de vraiment prendre va rentrer
des changes la française comme comme
principal défaut aussi sur mathieu ça
fait des vidéos avec moi et toi t'es au
courant
bah moi je serrais bon et maxime c'est
aussi les dessus c'était quoi là dessus
je pense de vote mais moi je sais quoi
donc est ce que tu peux nous expliquer
affable le fou et 6 pourquoi pas d'amal
7 on peut faire de mieux soit mieux de
me prénomme et de soif ou france on
reprend mais disons fouquereau on fait
juste une finale un poil mieux les jeux
tu as parfois f5
non tu as un peu mais joe pesci rock
tour un tel premier à prendre la colonne
eux
et voilà il ya carlson qui avait joué
c'est un peu il avait battu hakobyan je
crois en croûte chez ce livre là dessus
il a gagné notre comble it et tiennent à
jouer ça voilà et il raccroche 7 c'est
faisable été un peu les mêmes soucis
pat était pas tout à fait à temps pour
un talent fou qui angers 5 la nature
bon c'est en fait c'est jouable pour
l'année en tous les cas et même en plus
enfin c'est juste accepte en convient
mais il faut aussi c'est normalement
c'est censé être pas mal pour organiser
kg 5 qui va s'ouvrir d'amsatou dan 17
d'amos est un truc intéressant fable
c'est que en revanche peut-être pour
maxime s'est passé
idiot de ne pas prendre de risques et de
faire deux nuls et de voir ce qui se
passe à côté qua non monsieur
non mais là il joue pour être un peu
mieux oui oui mais c'est alors tu t y
aller si ringarde mais ouais mais c'est
devenu connu ce fut aussi ce que c'est
mieux que dams est et de la finale même
si la finale à vrai dire ça acceptable
donc la feda me saquer prend 1,6 mais
bon on enlève prendre au nom de satin
terrestre est entré le mv elle si tu te
qualifier aux candidats s'ils se
qualifient au canada soit mais ce que
c'est intéressant pour lui ça se fait
notre histoire cueillir il deviendrait
peut-être trop fort non mais disons ok
dejagah etienne c'est très bien et ce
tout entouré pour la prépa charge peut
aider à bosser un peu ou quoi mais t'as
mieux comment apprendre ça ce serait
beau que tu dis ça que tu fais comme les
mecs dans marche
j'ai peut-être été trop bien préparés
qu'ils fabriquent en jeu dès peut-être
peut-être trop bien pas c'est beau
qu'est-ce que je n'en aurai je peux
venir pour jouer au mini king ponts ou
des choses très intéressantes mais juste
pour faire des échecs
ss qui tu as trop subtile trop
intelligent ça c'est elle qu'est ce que
tu veux pour un faible je suis trop fort
tellement aimé c'était juste pas ces
gens-là rêve de cette émission télé mais
moi j'avais su j'aurais dû twitter en
parler à fou c'était extraordinaire il
aurait peut-être été trop partie chiche
à ali bongo je veux dire oui nancy maxi
la donne main d'oeuvre qui tous fourni
les ordis de ouf et qui te deum il
travaille ça à fond ça je peux faire
mais mais bon jusqu'au bout ça de but en
blanc je vois pas trop l'intérêt pour
lui c'est comment il s'appelle
macaq un second temps qui est de 1300
lots 2100 c'est le mec qui fait de
l'ordi qu'on fait il lui dit pas ce
qu'il a vu il s'appelle comment déjà
s'appelle il a un nom marrant mais tu
vois c'est pas littlefinger mais mon
avis très personnel et que je pense que
seul saut pourrait venir gripper la
machine du paquito fimo ouais mais en
fait si maxime gagné avec bonus ce match
je crois que sauf à ce qu'il veut c'est
déjà trop tard
oui non non non s'il prend tous les
points n'est pas calculé ci prend tous
les bonus il fait il fait 12 points
mm100 française de maxime à xiii et la
si belle sauvetage à trois points et
puis en plus d'un point de vue est 4 et
6 gagner un point bonus oui bah ouais
c'est ça s'ils gagnent des points bonus
c'est bon mais s'ils gagnent pas le
point bonus que sow prend tous les bonus
il peut encore le dépasser en revanche
si sauva au départage qui gagne et que
maxime gagne c'est fini voilà exactement
donc en réalité je pensais quand même
mieux pour maxime si c'est si c'est ce
qu'ils gagnent en réalité l'autre
l'autre match est pour le moment et
c'est une grue de feld trouvé en est
votre style à petit de ruines là c'est
quoi la théorie femme après après prise
prises l'as bondy ont essuyé plusieurs
coups vous faire ces trois peut faire
petit rock
quel est des deux quais d'essayer pour
revenir vers eux cinq puisse pas se
balader temps je fais cahier des deux
pour cavaliers trois cavaliers cinq mois
je suis je suis basique tu fais quoi tu
fais rock cavaliers f3 et ses 5 et une
hausse le seuil de 5 ou 6 genre qualités
de glisse ici
ok admettons bon je te fais kf3 tu vas
jouer du rock et puis tu veux dans ce
sens qu'au prochain
ok je rock tu valence 5 que je te prends
tu prends jeu
je comprends que tu fais ça par exemple
comme finale juste une question
c'est aux grands maîtres que je parle un
nom mais je crois que ça va d'autres on
triche comme la paire de fou oui oui
mais bon y'a pas assez d'eux c'est pas
énorme
il ya eu une partie je veux comme ça
entre kovalev et la mi hyun une partie à
amical ou à nouveau un peu le tournoi b
du tata steel
ah oui aujourd'hui et gendarmes oui une
partie amicale voilà c'est beau et un
tracking qui ne comptait pour rien
travail c'est tellement dur d'avoir un
niveau tu vois comme je me dis lamy ou
kovaliov pourquoi tu as les mecs sont
super forts bonne et en fait ils n'ont
jamais accès aux circuits pas j'ai envie
de dire pro entre jazz qui veut dire
généralement villa vous l'appelez
circuit pro puisque en quelque sorte
enfin je pense que c'est un peu le bon
mot non circuits pros arrêtent je veux
dire ils ont jamais accès à statuer
évite d ouais ils ont ni accès au
tournoi fermé privé où il ya beaucoup
d'argent ni accès aux trucs qualificatif
pour pour le titre de champion du monde
ou quoi donc en fait c'est assez
frustrant tt genre 70e mondiale 80e
mondiale est en fait pas du tout j'ai
cru qu'un droit c'est chauffage a même
compté 15 20e mondiale comme artémias
comptes axa rien ouais c'est vrai que tu
fais pas les grands prix du fait tu fais
rien bref il va devoir c'est minable ça
changera un jour mais faut votre pouvoir
y remonte à 2008 s'en est vraiment dire
bon bah je suis là quand même le plus
que ses à côtés quoi oui c'est vrai que
ça c'est un truc qui on en pensant qu'on
parle souvent des tournois tout ça c'est
vrai que c'est quelque chose d'un peu
difficile ceci dans les échecs c'est à
des gens qui sont même moins bien que la
sécurité n'y ait eu une taupe alors fui
l'axé si tu veux te pas love c'est bien
ok boomer vient jouer deux tournois
quads électriques par tu vois topalov
guelph en devenait artemiev on tue n'a
été que 13e mondial tu ne nous intéresse
pas tu es tu es trop jeune beaucoup plus
intéressant si on va on va faire revenir
smith love d'ailleurs d'entre les morts
de toi bien jouer le tournoi toi non
mais tu vois c'est un peu cruel je
trouve
c'est pas à prétendre et toujours les
mêmes joueurs et tu ouvres les tableaux
et fait d'être inquiets tition avant et
c'est un peu comme au tennis
non mais là du coup il ya copains tu as
que fait iakovenko dans ce grand prix
s'il ya pas retenir fait je comprends
pas je sais pas mais fait le truc c'est
que au moment où ils ont fait la liste
peut-être que sur la moyenne ne sais pas
quoi iakovenko et plus cartésiens
justement votre constat a été fait mais
c'est un truc comme ça on est d'accord
que c'est quand même un peu fort de café
quoi je guy je n'en peux plus de ce ok
bouveur une réponse pour le regard
justifié
ouais bah écoute c'est la puissance du
truc barret c'est hyper chiant fait
l'offre l'expression et ccc c'est là que
tu en penses sur sa puissance arrêtant
il a fait cavalier des deux mois donc
les suisses qui se sont un temps mon
seul guide
way back et 6,6 france ok rock j'y crois
pas d'embarquer pour quatre cavalières
froissé plus ou moins forcé europe
bon là j'ai envie de dire 'ok sega mega
logique de saint lô skylogic moi tu
bouffes je fais bouffer quatre îlots et
franck grand cas des français par le
biais d'un enfant je pense logique aussi
d'un proche de menace c'est fait tu fais
d'un projet 5 c en belgique est fou qui
fait ce t3 et jean les enfoncer 6
ouais mais c'est bon en fait si ça
rentre là dedans parce qu'on a déjà
lâché à l'information et avait quasiment
dix minutes c'est peut-être qu'on y sera
dans vingt minutes quoi
c'est bon de parler de hockey les
boumeurs à des choses beaucoup plus
intéressantes du coup oui on peut jeter
un oeil ont jeté un petit oeil à un écho
quand même parce qu'il ya un intérêt
mais cette date de la théorie pure et
dure ça non fab dans la dans la green
fields
je suis moins experts mais est ce que
tout ça peut passer de 1800 oui bah oui
oui peut un jour on vers un pas pour
l'instant mais on a déjà parlé ces
préparations sont un peu un peu légère
c'est son problème
il joue très bien mais il faut passer la
vitesse tu vas ne vous prépare donc
qu'il s'entoure ouais ça va coûter de
l'argent nature on en parle et on en
parlait avec avec six rounds genre
c'est cher et pas cher à la fin on
comprenait pas je passe tester assure
sur ce stream on en parlait vu l'argent
qu'il ya dans les échecs que tu as
wlasny dewey mais pour un fil rouge
actuellement un budget de 150 mille
euros par an pour avoir vraiment une
très bonne prépa mais en réalité c'est
un vente mille euros c'est rien par
rapport à ce qu'ils gagnent du coup tu
pourrais prendre je suis humaine firouz
je suis pas sûr qu'il y avait
aujourd'hui une ordonnance à vivre même
si ça peut être un investissement sûr
l'avenir mais bon faut trouver des
crédits quoi où le mec qui te
sponsorisés qui te prend un pourcentage
juste et a récemment fait qu'on va
pouvoir lisez un mec comme chirugien je
lui dis je te prends 50% de thé zone
horaire pendant dix ans et je te file
150000 euros par an sur cinq ans
admettons ok mais ça c'est un bon deal
en gros ça me coûter 600 cartes voix
pour toi c'est un bon deal lui balyo si
on va dans le nom mais en fait pourquoi
ça arrive jamais dans les échecs jeu
cela on en discute on dit était un
venture capital tu fais ça va peut-être
en fait tu leur as complètement quoi
c'est beau non mais tu crois en lui
tu l'aies des internautes pour son
investissement éventuellement brighi non
mais ce serait un bon dieu mais oui en
fait c'est ça mais le truc il faut bon
les cent cinquante mille par an lacharme
moi je peux pas les matches fermés pour
un fonds de pour un fini par en fait
ouais nan mais pour un fonds
d'investissement ces zones non mais même
tu trouves pas il ya des gens riches qui
peuvent eux qui veut le faire et se dire
tiens ok je vais razeq ça ouais non mais
ces fatwas c'est vraiment pas idiot
c'est vraiment pas idiot après
évidemment ça c'est comme tout
investissement tu prends ici avec se
démotivent qui commencent alors les on
voit qu'entre midi ou en soirée avec non
mais ça non mais ça tu peux tu peux
faire un accord pour pour être pour voir
ce que tu paye enfin ça c'est ce n'est
pas obligé de lui donna vie tu peux
payer les entraîneurs directement dans
ceux qui vont façonner le club
ouais non mais bien sûr que tout est
fait un bon contrat et pirro déjà je
pense qu'il serait intéressé et toulouse
s'intéresse
mais oui en fait mais bon c'est comme
aux etats-unis quand tu devais faire et
dans têtu tu dois emprunter l'argent
bien sûr et après
après on fera un bon boulot tu prends
rembourser non mais tu vas juste c'est
une solution intéressante qu'on avait
qu'on avait eues mais je crois que
c'était avec ses soit avec force avec
mathieu cornette mais je passais dans le
chat à ce moment là mais bon disons non
mais moi je sois moi je pense qu'il
disait mathieu aux sujets web je crois
que c'est un mec là il y avait même des
mecs dans le chat qui avait réagi qui se
dit ouais enfin c'est c'est hallucinant
que ça arrive jamais parce que c'est
vrai que tu as même pour good à padoue
d'attentes envoie ta envoient de
l'argent comme ça si seydou là il doit
être pas loin de les gagner 150 banques
je sais pas car il a fait 3e ou seconde
je connais monde de blitz une fois il a
fait un peu quelques grandes pièces pour
par ci par là donc c'est quand même le
truc le plus d'argent à les grands prix
bas il a joué il a fait des résultats
corrects ils jouent les ligues donc pas
être loin de les avoir
est ce que tu vois je me disais si si
ammann et on a investi sur trois quatre
joueurs comme ça d'avenir site en a un
qui est champion du monde en fait tu
rembourses tous les autres et avec les
autres en fait tu battu voilà ils sont
les bénéfices qu à la fin il y en a un
qui te couvre tous les frais et puis les
autres sites sont les bénefs non mais
voilà fast juste un truc dont on parlait
et ont beau nom mais sûrement souvenirs
de personnes et inclut 150 cas pas sur
quels points d'autant plus bas à bas
coûts n'est qu'il faudrait créer un
fonds d'investissement de beats
triompher percée fille rouen le plume en
badgeant l'interdît stream et certains
faits se situent strydom entonné une
clause dans le contrat était déjà dans
un état déjà tu rembourses ans que tu
rembourses en fait ça et tu nous dois de
l'argent des achats pour exprimer non
mais en fait peut-être que même 50
milles ça suffisait parce qu'en fait je
veux dire tu payes quelqu'un pour être
un emploi temps avec toi viens un mec 26
50 27
j'y connais bien et tu dois achète un
bonheur dit et tu dis ok tu fais que ça
pour 50000 va être content de moi je
pense le mec faut qu'ils aient au moins
26 60 non non je pense 26,55
ça peut être un peu juste à partir de
26,60 tu trouves des mecs plus
qualitatif déjà et donc bad ont du coup
[Musique]
50000 c'est sur deux ans
manutan admettons tu maigri tchouk aussi
seconds auraient tués deux sont lors de
ces jeux qui veut pas être seulement web
grève annoncée après les candidats tu
prends après les candidats s'y prend sa
retraite
oui on va où tu prends un mec non mais
tu as besoin d'un joueur retraités ou
semi-retraités je prends pas dûment
l'écho tu aura jamais un joueur de
l'élite
voilà non tu fera l'écho tu vas voir des
gens qui joue plus trop
c'est tout ce que tu peux avoir en fait
elle est complètement bon il y en a pas
non plus des masses mais tu peux prendre
des mecs semi actif mais qui sont pas
dans l'élite levitte et est moins cher y
tuent leur finale mardi pour faire du
bon boulot comme ouais non mais tu fais
tu fais tu fais une équipe de troyes et
voilà est une arme et tu vois tu fais un
investissement vraiment sur 4 5 ans
étudie de toute façon dès la 2è 3è année
dès qu'ils rentrent dans le circuit va
se faire 500 cas par an donc tu vas être
largement remboursé le truc c'est qu'il
faut qu'il faut qu'ils y rendent quoi
ces salles à risque c'est que s'ils
rentrent pas tu es mal mais bon il va
éventrée ils devraient rentrer compris
on met même en fait s'il rentre pas trop
et qui est qu'il est que 15e mondial en
fait tu vas tellement fort retour sur
investissement sur des dix années
facilement oui sur les dix années oui je
dis ah tu trouves des bons clubs belges
en bundesliga il va jouer le top 12 ils
joueront les guides pagnol le parti par
la bombe a tué près de nous et s'ils
gagnent tout le temps c'est monté bien
bas ce qui devrait bientôt faire fermer
les pros dont donc je vais remettre le
lien il ya un an un abonnement d'un an
ou 1
une série vidéo du duplex de la gagner
nos choix bah ouais en fait j'ai décidé
l'apport en stream donc j'ai remis le
lien vers le discorde pour presque
participer aux pronos ça peut encore
prônons tarde de voir la fin voilà c'est
des idées tu vois qu'on a pour pour
développer peut-être même les échecs ça
c'est vraiment un sujet intéressant mais
web après plusieurs légalement constat
est ce que tu peux juste faire un
contrat entre deux personnes comme ça un
bassiste club très bien c'est sûr que ça
se fait un fab
non mais bah écoutes je sais pas
pourquoi c'est pas plus peur d'être non
mais c'est une question qu'on se posait
vraiment ce que tu as à blaye dit ouais
mais c'est dur de trouver les finances y
ont discuté là dessus dit ouais mais
quand même c'est de retrouver les
finances lamizana n'a jamais en fait
c'est dur d'être les finances il ya
tellement d'argent dans les gestions et
que ça me paraît au contraire très
simple si tu eu sa part est vraiment
très simple mais genre moi j'aurais
accepté j'ai un truc
bon maintenant ça ne se faisait mais
quand j'avais 20 ans au guardian
ouais bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr on a
des idées on a des idées mais bon tu as
moi ce serait pas un sponsoring la
sponsoring type est en voie de l'argent
et a pas de route se serait ce serait
vraiment un investissement ces deux
choses très différentes chance est plus
facile de trouver de l'argent pour un
investissement pour un sponsoring
n'existe espère gagner de l'argent en
sabots au passage peut-être quelqu'un
tant mieux il t'a pas parce que douche
ou quoi là on s'arrête à paris se fout
après c'est une troisième guerre
mondiale ou quoi il y aura moins de 3
des chèques si quoi c'est une troisième
guerre mondiale
1 oui bon voilà ok tu peux y aura moins
de troupes aux attentes ouais mais bon
état des risques
c'est la fin du monde
comment tu comment tu fais ton retour
sur investissement
ouais mais est ce que ce sera ton
problème posé est mais bon un joueur
violent
on nous dit au tennis ça existe de ceux
dont vous parlez oui je sais je sais en
fait ce que nous occupions poker c'est
un peu différent dans le sens où il
plaidé
inscriptions aux tournois et matchs mais
au tennis wii saïd bahaji quand j'avais
le camp quand je suis avec le gard la
quête qui a été top 1000 mondiale ils
disent en fait quand tu as un gros à
venir tu as juste des gens qui
t'envoient fin à cette c'est très cher
de faire le circuit mais s'ajuste des
mecs qui croit en toi et qui t'envoient
et qui t'envoient de l'argent pour que
tu puisse aller faire les tournois et
après une fois que tu rentres dans le
top 50 mondial main pour le mec c'est
tout bénef
ils seront battus pour ne pas que
l'arrêt de la secte a investi temps ça
tu peux investir en es tu prends firent
oudjani al sarine mme asha fin en temps
prend 3,4 et puis tu dis bah voila si on
a un qui rendent sa rembourse tous y en
a deux qui rentre c'est jackpot bon
escient les héros qui rentre je suis un
con et puis enfin attentifs à waimes tu
as même pas perdre ton temps frais non
mais sérieusement ils vont quand même
gagné quelque chose d'autre à 100 quand
même quelque chose un petit peu quelque
chose qu'elle dise au foot cela existe
aussi le joueur tevez appartenait à des
hommes d'affaires argentins ça existe
dans book chaussée je prends je suis
étonné que ça n'existe pas dans les
échecs ça donne quoi mvl écouter on va
retourner c'était complètement égal
talent heures mais comme on web on
écoute il est en train de se passer
exact
ah non il a fait rock y aura toujours
mais de toute façon ça m'arrangerait de
jouer je pense alors après peut être
qu'il jouera pas que les deux c6 qui va
jouer ces cinq ou quoi mais là on peut
toujours faire des procès à ce moment là
et c'est devenir miss et les classements
cavaliers 3
et puis un plan parfois ce serait de
jouer avec ses 4 avec les banques mais
très typique pour essayer de créer
l'échangé jouer sur un fuseau les une
faiblesse et si tu provoques des quatre
du coup tu dois font sourire caisse
blanche parce que tu as plus de fous de
cases blanches c'est le nom est ici
énorme touche en rien des changements
bon ok c'est pas forcément la vie depuis
pastis mais ces deux médias non l'idée
vraiment je pense que faire au 5 c'est
naturel ça c'est vraiment très très
logique mais et donnant quand même pour
maxime sur une française de se faire
égaliser en force 1 mais il y va jouer
sa petite finale c'est tout non mais
c'est dangereux la française soit sûrs
andrée gros de vente de convard et tu
peux perdre
es-tu réfute pas comme ça c'est pas ta
pas davantage en claquant des dents ap
ce qui a aidé de ses 5 c'est quand même
là au troisième coup ce qu'un problème
dont 4,6 des quatre des cinq qui a aidé
de ses cinq je sais pas exactement mais
davantage pour les blancs ben je l'aï
dit en fait il va en d1
en fait là tiscali quentin commenté ça
il est dieu qui te fait cavalier c3 si
tu veux davantage qui arrive si oui mais
il y en fait tu le trouveras pas
messieurs les avantages bien joué ça me
met des petits aux grands maux tim k
mais il dit même cavalier d2 mieux que
prend dé 5,8 jeudi même qui a validé
deux succès fou puis pas pourquoi même
parce que moi je trouve ça n'a pas l'air
mal mais non le gramme de ces cinq du
tout souligné que dans le pro destin que
tout ça en fait
objectivement ça va très bien mais c'est
un sage ou c'est pas d'être dont un
quart et qui ne me signale une
excellente partie côté côté russe bah
écoute et on va la regarder non c'est le
petit karoo jeunes avec des trous mais
karekin qui a fait quand même l'exploit
de passer au second tour
fin de droit il n'a pas gagné une partie
ça fait 5 ta grosse game peut dire non
non non il ya eu aucune erreur
donc tu disais par contre j'étais coupé
parce que c'était un peu le l'événement
qua non médecins savent à kayes c3 ses
chaudrons même la win over mais bon je
pense faire une overdose possible outre
quelque chose comme pour les pour les
blancs s'en fout et 4 mai qui j'ai déjà
je sais pas du tout sajoo fins et en
fait tu peux lui tout casser les dents
si tu auras des positions alors jouer
on sait des matchs élimination directe
en échange bon bah t'as rien mais si les
noirs sont va presti déjà fait quelque
chose on dit je crois que la défense
française n'a jamais été réfutée depuis
petrosyan diallo me catala même avant je
veux qu'on me laisse un parti officiel
bah ouais mais tu as fait que des nuls
non non non je n'ai pas de haine mais
rogers jeu trois fois ou 4 j'ai envie de
te dire heureusement en fait si tu
l'avais pas grave j'ai joué quatre fois
non mais j'ai jamais gagné mais non 4 x
3 nuls et henri physique hommes d'amara
quest ix gagner je n'ai jamais vu un
grave est aussi faible de ma vie s'est
il joué jeu c'est un combat ça aurait
été extraordinaire voilà tu as perdu une
partie ça va il m'a déjà proposé je
compte plus tu te donnes pas ton dernier
tournant c'est à nice en 2005 par
l'ingestion avaient fait nul
j'avais fait nul c'est une partie du
matin ah oui mais il ne les compte pas
en fait ouais mais moi non plus des
comptes pop toi c'est très dommage manon
étudiants c'est une partie du matin je
connais je lui ai dit oui tu as perdu
contre eux ou nina lacarrau cannes et me
dit non by vivent ici je connais la
partie hi-media oui mais c'était c'était
le matin gibraltar donc du coup
ah bah non il n'a jamais perdu en fait
non ça tombe dans ce qu'on raconte
donc c'est vrai c'est ce parti là c'est
une moderne javel et blanc qui coûte
c'était pas mal mais bon nul
ok j'avais perdu au national en 2006
j'ai l'énorme catalan tout allait très
vite l'explosion en plein vol
c'était une bonne idée en fait
d'affronter deux pas de là dessus mais
bon c'est comme ça j'avais fait nul une
fois aux championnats d'europe
aix-les-bains s'être en 2011 mais va
n'était pas du tout en forme mon stand
j'ai parce qu'il aime ça compte pas non
plus dû vous rendre possible l'arrêt de
chance pas songé une défaite sur une
partie des avis et l'autre jour on a
fait nul n'a pas vraiment joué ok
peut-être que je t'aime aussi pour
former ce national
non oui et ça compte pas en fait c'est
toi qui est en forme tu as perdu
c'est fait tu as joué à son vrai niveau
donc servette est situé en forme que
c'est étonnant
oui j'étais beaucoup trop en forme c'est
mais voilà mais après mon but c'est tout
c'est pas mal quand même
oui ça va bon ça me rassure ça à vos
ratios normand fait ok la deuxième
partie n'existe pas on va dire j'ai vu
que trois fois leïla elle-même toi même
toi tu reconnais non mais enfin quand
vas tu gagnes le matin ça compte bien
sûr parce que même le matin j'ai réussi
à le battre
tu imagines à quel point il est nul quoi
même le matin pour te dire et c'est beau
très content il participe à temps quand
tu dis est avéré brownie quoi mais plus
on était juste préparé par ou blessent
qui je n'ai pas joué contre el faro cfaf
mais je veux contrôler un trépas de
roublev ce qui plombe l que tout en
entretenant un ventre oui mariage on en
a parlé à 20 minutes bon il ya fou 3 5
est possible d'apprendre à me concerne
c'est normal mais il faut prendre est
possible bref on prend et assure x 4
fait pas toujours 8 je crois qu'il faut
défendre kung fu et juste comme ça toi
ouais mais en fait j'aurais joué 17 mars
j'aurais juste aidé à me prouver 5 perso
je le serai parents aiment aussi mais je
crois que ça va tout voir en fait non ça
peut faire une huile très rapide un ba
en fait si juste mac simulation pas et
composants nul mais tu peux jouer la
finale
en fait c'est objectivement plus ou
moins égales mais tu es sans risque 1 et
clément donc tu peux jouer un peu con
non exactement justement il veut donc ça
nous coller fait main basse à peu près
égales en patois donc si damien basset
la partie je pense qu'il va jouer un
coup comme si ces 3 6 6
on se sent un peu tes pousse à peu près
égales en fait
j'aurais quand même nous féliciter femme
parce qu'on a lâché cette position à
14h05
14h06 est pour être exact pour pare
chocs le tchad non mais ça fait plaisir
pas de 28 ans raconte pas n'importe quoi
enfin on est là tout en train de
discuter et de faire les clowns et tout
ça mais enfin pourquoi pas ce qu'on
prévoit 25,8 à l'avant sans ordinateur
honteux prévoit la partie quand même ça
c'est pourquoi mais qu'est ce que je
vais en fait on va tu serais plus
content avec les blancs de pions des 500
m cette année encore la stat est pas sûr
de gagner mais c'est plus cool cela a
généré une colonne il une case au 4 pour
le cavalier revenir dessus parfois
c'était un donc et c'est donc moins
ouverts du coup ouais il faut dire aussi
que comme c'est un pion central comme
très souvent en fait les pions sans trop
basse et fort pas quand il très simple
au centre avec l'adversaire on n'a pas
assez fort voilà sept blocs de demel
pour les fous c'est que garbi 100% deux
défaites contre vlad mais vous arrivez à
prédire ce que les super j'aime jouer
oui mais justement c'est bien pour ça
que vous perdez cela semble déjà nul
pour les pronoms demande florence jette
c'est plus probablement nulle mais ce
n'est pas encore fini du tout je crois
qu'il lui dit vlad connaissait déjà
toute la partie à 14h02 je savais déjà
comment ça les deux joueuses central
park à new york
mais je crois pas qu'ils jouent dans
central park en fait aux échecs c'est
plus d'autres endroits mais ouais j'ai
essayé de jouer c'est sympa ça pas grand
chose c'est juste pour le leader faible
intérêt que cyril of film and 1 0 contre
vlad
oui mais aussi un matin non rester une
partie du matin cyril off ça qu'on prête
je crois que c'est une première ronde
donc là non à bas la grande parade
dommage arrighi non c'est pas le matin
et c'est peut-être la première ronde
ça compte pas non plus en fait il a
plutôt de se chauffer et petits fachos
troisième ronde à bassa compte alors faf
enfin est ce que les troisièmes monde
détourne raconte vraiment enfin c'est un
peu la question qu'on se pose maintenant
par ben laden appelle raconté un truc
marrant quand il a joué contre kasparov
ouais à la can ouais en fait il me dit
que quand il a rejoint en amical contre
lui ils ont fait 3 3 ouais mais me fait
quand tu joues en officielle contre
kasparov s'est pas du tout la même chose
il aura le web à spa dans les échecs
mais dans la pression autour mais ce que
vlad à affronter car c'est vrai il a
d'ailleurs battu une fois tu peux voir
la butte montmartre une vidéo sur wii
party exceptionnel dont aucun n'est pas
étonnant combien faut-il que je boive
pour ne pas le battre est-ce qu'il a
joué une fois moscou complètement bourré
aussi comme j'ai plus à y perdre ou pas
mais a été complètement revu une fois il
a perdu mais je pense à la fois il a
perdu une fouine défaut il a perdu envie
de ça j étais été complètement plus
extraordinaires ces blocs rêve d'aller
jouer contre carleton complètement
défoncé quoi salut à toi si la dinde
jamais été champion du monde c'est pour
ne pas tuer les échecs
exactement il avait raté ma tant de noms
dans le blitz je crois qu'il avait
c'était pas contre grid ou qu'il ait
raté ma temps de jeu c'est un peu
importe on parle un peu de tout et de
rien parce que fab on va pas se mentir
la partie est intéressante la position
qu'on a sous les yeux ça a été une fois
donc c'est la partie de jeter si des
tels entre covire fait il a mis s'était
confiée comme en bas du coup je te dire
parce que ça peut être intéressant
[Musique]
jean robin faut que je trouve les coups
on a envie et passion c'est rend les en
fait ben oui les deux cavaliers
3 tu peux aussi jouer que cette fois
avoir plus dans une position avec un
cavalier en plus sur les chicken tu
trouves que et yanni fait en fait
récemment
j'adore ça exact c'est possible aussi
et donc nous pour la partie kovalev
l'ami y avait eu d'âpres en hockey
français 3,6 fou des deux qualifiés 4 je
sais pas ce que ça vous met même te
faire foi f4 pour et charles et henri iv
mais j'ai 3 way foot c'est ça de foudre
pour prouver si tu vois la pression sur
s2 faut deux battants et son cavalier
il est parti un f6 arrive à revenir vers
leucate voilà ce qu'il ya eu 5 6 4
don kelly et 6 c 4 des blancs logique
que c'est d'ouvrir un peu fou b6 mans
exactement c'est rendait il lui a fait
l'intermédiaire est ok tours 1 1
j'avais dit aux quatre airs plus ou
moins floues trois bourses et reprend 10
à cesser complètement nuls ou blancs et
nuls 20 coups plus tard mais bon non
mais c'est là il a fait ces trois c'est
vraiment le sénat fin c'est vraiment le
scénario de parti qui risque
probablement arrivé un truc
après vous sûr que le gunner faut être
un peu vigilance tu fais trop rien que
ceux des blancs mettre en place tu peux
peut-être même en gros ce que je bats ce
que je pense de l'expérience que j'ai
puisque je joue parfois genre de
position avec mon répertoire un peu
bizarre c'est que si tu échanges les
fous de cases noires s'est tout de suite
rien genre tu mets une tour en 1 8 si tu
réussis à faire flouer 4 mètres les
tours en 1 8es échanges et une paire de
tours c'est déjà cédé j'arrête mais tu
mettras le roi en des six essais juste
fini tout de suite gagné qui vient vers
le cadre des cuves et f4 et c'est mort
n'achetez que david monte pour autant
département en fait la partie je
connaissais par coeur je
vérifiez la surface base après je suis
connaissait à peu près jusque là je sais
que ça va pour les noirs mais après la
suite de la partie voilà près on connaît
pas tant de partis que ça sonne et pomy
hachey mon avis faut que nepomniachi
fasse attention soyons en train de tous
les jouets tempo mais j'ai l'impression
qu'il est en train de lui coller une
prépa long oui je traîne pour se dire ce
que ça veut dire
je serai pas je serai pas rassuré côté
côté russe la bonne écoute
je donnerai une deuxième wild card dans
la 2 cette année
cavalier à 5,1 me dise pas terrible
voici les experts de gaulle qui disent
que si en bon mais qu'il ya 5 oui c'est
un des problèmes de la bonne file silva
va rebondir ça va je pense que c'est
vraiment une bonne nouvelle que six
aussi se gagne ah bon ouais ce que
maxime il va passer il va passer andré
kino pire en rapide et après faudra que
sow le battant avec le bonus et qu'il
gagne en finale avec le bonus face à un
moment donné faut arrêter bah oui je me
la mets pas toute la planète qui va
gagner avec des bonus sera un jour non
mais la finale ça va être en face à sa
patrie ni normand oui mais bon battre
mvl avec le bonus froid mais ben écoute
non mais tant de fin d'année ou pas je
sais pas en fait les deux cas ça peut
être une demi pas si simple le mieux
serait de gagner good for estiment en
fait là on est tranquille xo mais la
victoire avec bonus j'y crois de moins
en moins aujourd'hui je n'arrive
tellement pas avoir maxime gagné ça
bon c'est pas trop parti pour mais
peut-être c'est 90% de chances de nuls
et 10 % bien un truc comme ça
ce qui est quand même pas si nuls que
sandrine tabac non remis les pendules ou
enfin je veux dire par là que sont son
défaut principal c'est l'ouverture là il
a passé oui donc c'est peut-être plus
tôt 1,2750 27 60 après l'ouverture et je
vois pas comment tu bats un joueur de ce
calibre là dans cette position là
vraiment on verra un petit tempo sont
deux mots filent au tour à 8 et je
préfère les noirs ont quand même pas non
mais c'est pas mauvais tour à tour à ut
ça va tout à fait mais de là à préférer
les noirs même dès lors en fait c'est
qu'il n'y a pas non plus grand chose à
faire et que style jeu s'ouvre un jour
la perte ou elle peut parler c'est pour
ça que tu veut probablement échanger les
fous de cases noires émettent en carélie
sur quatre n'ont alors pas du tout
comment gagner un bonus en gagnant le
match en partie longue
voilà donc un match aller retour
bah si tu t'imposes soit 2,03 un ennemi
0,5
un tour du stade ben oui mais on l'a
fait le tour on retourne bon c'est ça
l'autre partie donc sow qui sort une
prépa animaux en fait les faits nouveaux
de 18 avec le 5 il fit l'objet convoité
mais du coup je sais pas gagné ça tu
verras que c'est un jour peut-être
laïque du fonds bkc rien enfin il a
drummer 1 à l'heure actuelle il a deux
points de retard
oui donc vous voyez on a joué assez vite
sous dame des eats keller - coupe tout
le regarder quand même ça il n'y a pas
cinquante candidats la position d'alain
m'excuse non tu vas te prendre food est
cafouillé cardan l'adaptable et 6 donne
des vies c'est cette idée sinon je suis
pas un cavalier de façon notable pas
1000 cases vous remettre enfin temps
après il faut le défendre
donc en gros si tu as toujours tempo ce
que la dame des eats eeckelaert a dû le
regarder la maison nivard il va
continuer à jouer larry de la ligne
numéro de l'ordi du co m sont en dialyse
donc samuel qui demandent si on pouvait
voir les stats des paris qu'elle paris
je pense sur sur ce qu'on a fait pour
l'abonnement mais là non là on ne peut
pas bon en gros il ya déjà eu une nulle
entre cariat qui est des oui bon geek ou
un bon spectacle et du coup il ya cette
partie là il n'y a que du bonheur le
deuxième tour
et voilà il a fait des six a plus ou
moins tempo mais joplin d'esprit mais je
crois que c'est hyper dangereux pour
n'est pour je pense aussi
je pense que dépôts non mais sûrement
que ça doit aller pour les noirs si tu
suis tous les bons coups je me souviens
non en revanche là où je suis d'accord
avec toi 100% c'est que si sow prend le
bonus et que maxime se fait éliminer là
je commence à faire dans mon froc
parce que ça veut dire que si sow gagne
le tournoi défi sans bonus c'est fini et
en jouant andré qui n'en demi et un
peintre en finale et il va être
écrasants favoris
il aura au moins 50% de chance de le
remporter
parce avait fait je vais pas trop me
serais dit bordry qui n'en fait prêter
jamais à l'abri d'un jardin déjà quant
aux plaques je voyais pas bomber sur
cette place et mais c'est pas 100% non
plus des familles qui du coup il n'est
pas au bout de ses peines il n'est pas
au bout c'est au meeddat ça va qu'il
trouve quelques vous précis va faire ou
pas tu es trop concrets comme je
pourrais juste quand on passe dessus
dire oui et il y en a effet d'un train
de finir troisième pion le sous thème
est justement barre des 5
ce qui nous fait peur c'est que ils
filent trois pions il analysé la
position à fond apparemment aînés peau
ne connaît pas forcément ça paraît très
dangereux mais bon des pauvres comme je
te
tout quoi qu'il en soit environ mais
j'ai l'impression fable que dernièrement
la grünfeld elle se fait un peu mal
traités bah en fait une ligne où les
choses sont assez fort c'est donc tu
peux bien viser ton adversaire allait
dans une ligne que tu as préparé à fond
l'autre n'étant pas spécialement
particulièrement et lui faire faire un
test de mémoire s'il se souvient pas tu
peux le planter donc c'est une période
dangereuse
voilà tu as dit si tu connais tous par
coeur en fait ça va mais si c'était pas
sûr et des ouvertures plus tranquille
genre des candidats mukwa cité pas
complètement sûr de toi au pire
troisième position solide hausse sera un
peu moins bien mais tu accordes de
drames qui vont se passer alors que la
grèce ait la merde
hollande lui on peut prendre b c est
effectivement mais c'est pas trop
l'objectif pour les blancs de récupérer
un pion et de perdre toute l'activité
notamment bordeaux au monde
non mais en fait c'est possible que ce
soit
soyez du v6 un jour à enghien d'une
qualité etc les blancs mais que au
québec adoption alors un truc comme ça
voilà ça reste à voir à quel point des
mieux puisque on les a empêchés de
fluidifier c'est à maintenir le fond le
5 c'est bien d'être en f1 je sais pas
bon je préfère avoir les blancs mais
peut-être ça pour les noirs ou des cas
tous ses singles j'étais d'avis tu sais
quoi faire ça ça doit tenir avec les no
way peut-être des quatre ou cinq
tu tiens tes deux pions pour les blancs
vous est offert dès h 4 h 5 à voir mais
bon ok ça peut être ça le truc
ou alors tu veux rien lâché et il faut
être très précis sion et de toute façon
les blancs doit avoir quelque chose pour
un minima égaliser oui
bonjour à tous qu'on joue maxime barnes
noble en train en fait mais c'est ça la
position sunward joué plein de cours à
tous les coups soit près similaire il ya
eu une partie déjà dans cette position
où les noirs avaient choisi de jouer ces
six jeux légitime comme goût du crunch
and options on tient bien mais jouer
tour à 8 il ya plein de coups possible
et c'est à peu près équilibré mais
jusque là on attendait un peu le coup
d'envoi équine en allant voir ce qui se
passe ailleurs
peut-être food et si ceci peut être un
coup pour pas avoir perdu le tempo c6
est tout de suite repartir vers du fou
c'est s'inclinant et pourquoi pas un
processus pas forcément fin c'était pas
forcément le coup de l'année non c'était
juste le coup joué que qui a l'air
d'aller dans l'absolu pour enfin celle
où j'irai et tout va mais tout va
peut-être mieux à faire mais pourquoi tu
perds tout d'abord d'agents de christian
ça pour elle en fait pour l'instant que
j'ai pas totalement ouvert pour les
blancs senor connectivité à l'est le roi
et tu peux te faire échanger un fou
aussi relativement facilement merveille
à la glace de 4,6 pour le il espère
fructifier là dessus comme maxime c'est
ont sauvé soir en fait oui bon j'ai à
perdre fou peut-être un jour ça ça
parlera ou pas mais il ya demain
d'incroyables cédant des changes je
comprends pas vraiment c'est pour faire
annuler non mais les bleus ont décidé
gagne pas il le joue pas pour faire nul
en tout cas dans les leçons que j'ai
traduite pourchasse points comme ils te
disent je prends des cinq jouable mais
ils te disent pas très intéressant ils
te disent le pion aux sigles six blocs
le fou c'est 8
et puis on prend des cinq pas logique
mantelis et jouables quand même mais
laisse beaucoup plus logique de protéger
ton pions ou de faire re 5 même chose
est bien mais plus grande ligue c'est
quand même ils le sont pour les joueurs
qui sont 1200 1300 un chat comme quand
on lâche des infos je fais un petit
teasing
bref un petit teasing à mai
c'est tu débutes les échecs l'info est
lâché même les meilleurs joueurs
mondiaux sont pas forcément autant au
point que ceux qui regardent les vidéos
et ceux qui regardent les vidéos ils
sont là ils te disent bon reprend des 5
tu as tu a permis au foot cases blanches
de se développer
c'est pas très logique erreur coup rouge
il faut bosser les bases non mais en
fait c'est pour moi c'est malheureux ce
qui se passe actuellement mais à cause
des ordures qua non mais en fait
maintenant les mecs qui jouent pour le
gain ils vont peut faire c'est 4 3 des 4
3 b 3 tu vois ce que je veux dire enfin
tu vois j'ai une cour un an
ouais alors que ça dans les années il ya
20 ans ou quoi tuer quelqu un jeu comme
ça l'autre non mais tu es prisée en fait
c'était juste rien quoi mais en fait vu
que maintenant les vrais trucs théorique
tu vas te réciter jusqu'au 40e coup et
tu vas faire nul à en force
tu en retourne pas quoi mais c'est
dommage comme ça comme ça les joueurs
n'y sont pour rien favre non mais là je
critique pas les joueurs ces deux
situations qui est dommage
tahar zolder bien fait en décharge la
france adresse ses travaux oui c'est ça
ou tu es la berlinoise contre les blancs
jouent pas pour la frime avec des 4 mai
font pour un cahier pro sen c'est la
structure qui arrive n'essayez pas ce
cas plus passionnant ses traits
symétriques jus qui dans les variantes
de l'ordi donné peau sol et noir donne
une qualité à aller va rentrer de leur
dis ça doit être ce qu'on a regardé à un
peu vain mais max est plutôt bon dans
les entrées de sang final comme il l'a
montré dans la berlinoise ou compte
iakovenko il était surtout super
préparer contre contre topalov dans les
berlines oise
il a juste réciter l'ordi et pour la
finale contient coven qu en réalité si
la commune qui joue bien il est à - 0 70
après quatre coups dans la finale non
mais pour le coup par ronde ou bien et
finalement non mais jerry joue bien mais
messina là tu vas pas bon on va voir un
vote et bas ce serait impressionnant
sylla ou de plaies andré keane là dessus
c'est pas impossible que je pense c'est
improbable j'y crois pas vraiment mes
potes je demande à voir j'espère
j'espère mais je pense qu'elle est pas
il n'y a pas assez davantage à l'est pas
c'est compliqué je pense qu'il a la
final la berlinoise on peut pas la
prendre comme une finale tu joues bien
les finales culture c'est encore très
théorique jusqu'au 30/5 coup en plus
vers max compter des petits travailler
avec expiant spiridonov ouais donc il a
sa culture il a ce truc
et voilà il ya plus comme il calcule
bien écrit final c'est important de bien
calculer
[Musique]
c'est que l'arcep a répondu quoi la
thalie culture plus calcul winants
forcément un effort mais c'est pas il
ajuste réciter leur vie ce dédain c'est
pas du dédain c'est difficile de dire
j'ai très bien leur installe la
berlinoise quand lui non ayant après le
début de la finale tu fais encore treize
ou quatorze coups de stockfisch ou lille
à zéro ou je ne sais pas qui mais c'est
dur d'appeler ça jouer précieux bien
joué parce que tu tues suite et
connaissances après une fois qu'il a été
bien il a il a bien fini mais
c'est pas une finale sur laquelle ont
planché c'est pas une finale sur
laquelle on peut juger et celle contient
coven qu elle n'était pas assez je
pensais pas non plus une finale sur
laquelle on peut vraiment juger mais
après il est précis joue bien il est
défend bien et sait mais là ça paraît
quand même un peu maigrichon que ce
qu'on a envie d'échanger un fou côté
nombre d'engagés 3 était joué et vite kg
je comprends alors on a mis le redis je
comprends juste qu'ils proposent à quai
et 17 pour jeffrey f4 imagine c'est
logique il faut 3 avec l'idée je
m'aligne sur x f4 vous prend à sept mois
à temps de se confirmer la main et je
pense que fait refouler 5,6 ok ça marche
ça marche il te fait fou p5q fait
toujours recette n'est pas non mais fou
c'est 6 de blocs tout il te bloque après
treize ordinateurs est ce que bon vous
passez sur thur en dedans varicent
trouve ça marche mais j'évite les lol
mais bon mais maxime il est capable
l'art de voir ce genre de choses
oui maxime il est capable de dire qui
avait 17 chf est fou et 3 et s'il fut f4
suis fou prend à 7 mac mac s'il peut
voir ça n'est donc plus qu à six par
exemple tour à tour à dire j'aurais joué
on a le temps et surtout des cats et
cinq bien je vais faire il faut prendre
quatre je pense que si tu arrives là
avec les noirs après c'est facile leur
tour eu un échange rock sound
ouais en gros c'est ça un site en arrive
là ça va pour les noirs tu peux même
échangé la tour les tours et mettre
leurs oeufs au centre escer final assez
jamais rien
ouais ok on sait vous demande c'est
qu'il met hors jeu en finale ou sur mon
capitaine
mais plutôt les finales à pousser car ça
ne pas les finales à défendre marque nf
en tout mais je le classe très
clairement au dessus des autres quand
c'est plus ou moins égales ou à peine
mieux ça c'est sûr après les positions à
défendre cette série qui me vient je
sais pas on va être un peu le même
défaut que capablanca magnus et finiper
un petit peu il veut un petit peu
s'énerver ou ou perdre même de
l'objectivité je dirai pas s'il a perdu
deux finales de tournoi carson qui était
posée de perdrix est tellement dans
l'autre sens c'est dans le sien jouable
sur des formules ou r non on va les
défendre tout le mur maxime défend bien
alors il ya vu qui sait si ce n'est pas
du prises en sept
il va reprendre
j'ai pas de quoi surprendre fouilla fou
prend ses six j'imagine mais même ça je
ne refais une heure ouais bon bateau
dans le port du cavalier doit dame de
d'adams où je suis à me prendre et du
cavalier prend mais c'est en baisse est
oui il faut savoir en fait tu vois ça
est ce que tous les choses et dans les
tribunes j'ai fait dame prend 1,7 on a
deviné je peux faire dans le bessin est
possible peut-être bon mais j'ai
l'impression que ça va au pied au pire
tu perds a et b et tubes l'inde avec un
cavalier quelque part il ya du jeu que
sur une aile égalité matérielle ça peut
pas être non non il ya d'autres chances
de nous moi je suis quand même convaincu
j'aurais préféré voir so gagner mais bon
après je suis pas fini le match
non non non pas d'être aujourd'hui aura
nul mais
mais il ya encore une partie demain et
peut-être des départage après mais du
coup déjà il y aura pas de bonus enfin
pas de bonus peut avoir bonus pour les
po1
en cas de victoire demain les dames ont
été échangés la partie de saut dames au
second tour prend besset et va prendre
best-of des français c'est sûr non mais
les blancs aux mille bonne pression sur
la tête mais c'est pas beaucoup ça va
ouais bah écoute soit à tenter un truc à
nous ils ont signé nulle c'est bon ok
soient tentés et dépôts a bien réagit
donc nulle rapide
bravo dépôt quand même un faux ouais
parce qu'on l'avait vu en difficulté
dans le premier match contre galles
fendent et est donc ça aurait pu être
on pouvait être inquiet pour lui pour sa
forme et aujourd'hui conso qui lui tend
une prépa il fait il sort il s'en sort
bien il fait nul finalement assez
facilement faut le féliciter des quatre
ça c'est très étonnant pendre au croc
aubin alors attends on peut un peu sur
ces quatre l'idée c'est quoi c'est de
reculer le fou c'est de faire ces cinq
ce que j'ai toujours peur de prendre un
blocus comme ça avec les noirs la cie
maximale fou détroit qui est un peu m
mais pas quelqu'un qui va arriver à 1,5
et ouais c'est pas encore ses 400 tonnes
jeudi caïds et 7 tu fais b4g même faire
[ __ ] 4 faut prendre tout reprend et je
vais vouloir faire cavalier 5 au
prochain et j'aimerais vous a pas
pouvoir se tourner quatre pas devenir
faible un joueur dans ses 5 et blanc
qu'avait lieu cinq tours à d un cadeau
va bouffer à gros seins mais bon on va
retour à l'arc tour de rester se
passerait
non mais qu'est ce qu'ils pensent et 4
ça se regarde prendre pas pendant les
quatre premières proactif donc ça t'as
pas envie takkal f4 ce bar et tu prends
des 4 depuis rien lyon mais sûrement cet
éphémère
je crois que le besoin f4 s'il tombe
tout de suite f5 et jetteront est obligé
de faire tourner ou quoi parce que des
tours d un ils reprennent cinq avocats
ça se met mal tout seul pour rien avec
le pion isolé c'est pas spezza et donc
f4 décision prend qu'ils soient justes
en faute
du coup tu peux pas faire grève sont sur
les dents longues et ça paraît tu va
rendre le pion juste et bon étape 1
le c4 docteur s'est cassé le coude plus
intéressant clairement qu'à et 17 b 4
faux f4 questionner lille a juste pour
qu'on ait un petit avis
b4 aussi faire ses 5 avec les noirs que
lila préfère ces quatre mots moi je sais
pas j'aime pas tant que ça il donne quel
pourcentage
bon reste 4 54 ans c4est donne 50 et
tout le reste c'est pas bien me fout les
deux jouables 52 en effet des deux va
jamais faire
j'aime pas le bon bilan ok un coup je
vois je comprends même pas s'il fallait
je comprends maintenant mais je rage à
marjah est tombé 1 mais en fait ça a du
sens parce que de nombreuses et 3 pts
ont brossé trotte attaque bessette et
peut-être même un coup de froid 6-4 à b4
qui suivraient ouais mais roquettes
bon ça jeu franchement s'il joue
toujours bien et voilà
mais donc ces 4 me semble plus
intéressant il aurait l'air de dire qui
a aidé cette des quatre peut-être est-ce
qu'on ait vues et ses 55 ans mais ces
deux variantes 5,3 fois ce week end
c'est bill donne plus ou moins 50
c'est plus ou moins ce qu on a vu un bon
là c'est fait tourner c'est c'est une
partie un simple et insipide aujourd'hui
quel nul en huit coups d'un côté nul en
vain de l'autre easy plus au combat ça
va être
yako et encore même pas sûr
même pas sûr mais dans les deux parties
en jeunes et enfin so i live un peu pas
dire que soit il est pas essayer il
était intrigué c'est un truc va pas
marcher au moins une finale maxime a
fait ces quatre quais logique est donc
le coup qu'on a investi 17 milliards ou
des six même genre d'idée évident b4e
paramètres cavaliers vers 17 5 août 5
bref ou des 600 premiers c'est pas idiot
mais le truc c'est qu'elle ait des
salles comme tu vois aussi jouer x 4,8
gare peut-être plus de flexibilité par
des deux coups non je suis je suis pas
inquiet mais je donne vraiment 95% de
chances de nul à présent et coup sûr
bien sûr mais à toi tu donne quoi
moi je veux beaucoup de chance deux nuls
mais pas plus pas moins que ce que je
racontais avant faite jeudi à 90 10
après faut pour les sacs dans
l'ouverture donc sa patrie
non mais c'est vrai qu'ils le système à
élimination directe n'est pas meilleur
que ça n'est pas meilleur que ça tout
dépend de la volonté des joueurs a gagné
le en réalité le système à élimination
directe il est bon si tu supprimes les
parties longues et là tu te retrouves
avec un système assez sympa août on va
durer sur
il ya autour ouais ça pourrait se jouer
mercredi jeudi et samedi dimanche
demi finales finale ou quelque chose
dans ce style là pour ajouter des
joueurs et des tours pour pour jouer sur
une semaine mais il est vrai que ce
système est bon si on supprime les
parties longues comme beaucoup de
systèmes d'ailleurs favori nal ouais tu
vas où les parties longues tu verras
quand c'est quand même une heure trente
qu'une heure trente est tuée voulaient 2
dans la foulée le même jour après que
c'est très long à tour trois jours trois
jours alors c'est très souvent ça se
joue dans les départager en fait et donc
à moi c'est pas tant que si tu avais pas
mais henry donc voila et deuxième truc
aussi comme t'as pas de gilet de
sauvetage
tu prend moins de risques aussi c'est
plus des salles d'art des positions plus
égale les jarres avantage tout à pas de
chance de perdre excès de l'embêter
temps adversaire plutôt qu'une guerre
totale logique des choses aillent herbe
ont des joueurs qui mène à 0 et qui a
touché 5 mai mais normalement tu fais
pas ça qui décide du format des partis à
la fidesz est le président il n'y a pas
moyen de faire pression négocier avec
eux pour un kursaal parties ne peuvent
pas ignorer sa non mais au contraire ils
sont pour allonger les parties est pour
et pour faire plus en plus long ce qu'il
faut comprendre l'ombre de kfc qu' il
n'y a aucun comme n'y a aucune logique
économique derrière on en a souvent
parlé on est obligé de se répéter mais
si tu veux ça marche comme un truc qui
est financé par parts et impôts par
groupe ares par de l'argent public ou
peu importe
et donc qui est trois personnes qui
regardent ou trois millions de personnes
ça ne change rien donc ya pas de moyen
de pression c'est comme si tous les mois
tu recevais un chèque de dix mille euros
et que les gens te dis bon bah tu peux
venir travailler
une minute ou ou 50 heures par semaine
tu fais comme tu veux
non mais c'est ça non mais pour le coup
vous effacez pas président de la fide
qui décide lui-même malgré son nom il
dort une commission bon alors qui est
dedans qui fait rimer gère par exemple
je vais avec la commission en soit elle
a aucune obligation enfin il n'y a pas
de toi il suffit que tes gars bien
qu'une lubie dedans et qui te dis oui il
faut très très lent et ça
trail en fait c'est pas vraiment les
joueurs qu'on a on va dire ni les médias
entre nous
non mais je veux dire par la fac que si
tu es dans un délire où le mec il a une
lubie mais si à moins de on va dire
60000 personnes qui regardent le mec est
viré bon bah là ça va aller ça lubie ça
marche pas bon mais là même si c'est
raté que sa rade depuis 50 ans de toute
façon ils seront toujours les mêmes
personnes qui se mettront entre eux pour
décider donc ouais puis 2-2 aussi de
voir des gens pas forcément hyper
compétent pour le coup mais qui t'ont
aidé à te faire élire ou qui ont
rapporté des voix ou je ne sais quoi
donc il était compétent dans un certain
domaine vont être que maintenant il est
là ce fut une commission bon ni pas
vraiment créatif ou quoi
mais après tu peux aussi bien tomber
quelqu'un qui te soutiennent et qui soit
en plus compétent pour le poste oui soit
mais ouais ça tombe mal tomber quoi
c'est peut être qu'il ya comme une conne
amara ça fait nul aussi falloir bomber
web des écoutes plus qu'une partie c'est
celle là
ouais je sais qu'une partie plus qu'une
partie devrait faire nul assez
rapidement j'imagine vont au paradis
il contient aussi messieurs proposé je
te propose pashtun pause on pourrait
imaginer faire les parties départager
deux parties l'ont bien sûr les obliger
à prendre des risques sur les longues
non mahdia de problème ça passe c'est
que déjà gelé vie dans aucun sport mais
le deuxième volet en fait c'est que tu
donnes prépondérance aux parties rapides
dans des bus dans un tournoi qui a
partie lente hier que le mec qui a perdu
les rapides
du coup le suicide est quelque part en
partie nantes ouais et donc chez pinsent
et plaisir c'est normal pour moi d'abord
joué lente parce que ça tombe à partie
lente
c'est ça qui compte en premier bond
bienvenue mais logique arrête je suis
d'accord avec toi y'a ex-aequo il ya
ex-aequo après tu va départager les
ex-aequo après tu perds tes tirs au but
oui oui non tu vois j'ai jamais vu ça au
foot que tu as eu des invasions se fait
des tirs au but
et puis bah du coup il ya 0 à la 80e
minute au g2
devancé tout le monde l attaque et voit
la pareille au tennis tout pâton
tie-break avant de 7 et ça dénature le
jeu le jeu en lui même c'est très
étrange a beau être une idée je dois
mais je sais pas je la sens pas je les
aime tant je souhaite à fait d'accord
avec toi femme je suis d'accord avec toi
à 200% fab
bon ça à faire ce probablement quatre
nuls aujourd'hui avec un cadeau de
tordre une époque à new york où je vais
te prévenu que je crois que ça changera
rien à terme sur le nombre de nuls non
mais en fait c'est pas grave qui ne va
c'est la vie y'a des fois tu as des
matchs de foot j'ai eu 4 4 nuls et on
s'est bien amusé et c'est sûr que si ça
qu'on sépare passe à dix dès le début tu
as moins t'amuser c'est juste ça la
différence mais c'est pas là nul en soit
le problème pour moi c'est pas là nul
c'est le temps que ça prend parce que si
si les parties durent dix minutes avec
les mecs qui font quatre nuls en réalité
il se passe quelque chose mais là c'est
long pour rien c'est ça le problème
c'est long pour rien alors
donc ce que fait celle jérusalem barbade
il accompagne maxime donc en fait il un
soutien moral
il doit peut-être l'aider un peu à
réviser des choses comme ça quoi mais
c'est ses couleurs quelqu'un avec toi
parce quand tu pars faire un tournant
dans notre pays que tu connais personne
enfin ou que les gens que tu connais ses
adversaires de façon ce n'était pas la
porte à me canaliser 3 avec eux le soir
où wall au resto a rigolé lendemain se
foutent sur la gueule quoi donc en fait
au lieu d'être tout seul dans mon coin
te prendre la pression plein fer au
moins tu as un bon ami avec toi qui ça
se passe bien que fama que celles en
fait il a il à y mettre sur la gueule
aux autres le soin qu'il reviendrait
avant sur la gueule au sens propre mais
très énervé parce qu'elle est forte
je ne soutiendrai pas avec eux s'ils
avaient passé deux fois alors je sais
pas pourquoi j'avais un autre truc à
faire un empêchement
mais jacques etienne doit quand même
pouvoir bosser à distance mais il devait
pas pouvoir déplacer pour je ne sais
quelle raison
mais seb c'est un bon choix en fait
parce que ils sont très amis saab était
souvent le capitaine l'équipe de france
avec lui ils s'entendent bien et les
marins ont quoi a donc donc là c'est
cool il est marrant c'est un mec
vraiment sympa à celle mais il va
t'aider à ça peut être trop stressé donc
le bon choix entre ses jambes a
d'ailleurs ça se voit
les résultats parlent 1 au bout d'un
moment
au bout d'un moment le résultat parle et
maxime qui semble quand même assez
tranquille dans ce tournoi contre
topalov il a été tranquille aujourd'hui
partie tranquille grc match à sa main
c'est son sang quelqu'un de das est
serein mon style j'aime ça va oui mais
ça fait longtemps que je pense qu'ils
étaient parle de cette joie un bon ok
pas encore un pas encore on espère qu'il
le devienne saad mazet ça fait déjà 15
ans que zimbo enfin pour peut-être 12
bon peut-être cave a lieu quatre ici
pour les noirs semblent être un coup tu
t'en prends au fouet tu veux viser la
casse ces 5
c'est une option l'autre option serait
que 17 pour jouer ces cinq cavaliers ou
cinq noms mais oui oui ces laitues asus
les deux coups qui viennent en premier à
l'esprit que 4 et 17 les deux sont très
bien franchement je serais curieux 4 moi
aussi je gagne toujours un tempo sur le
foot tu veux revenir faire en fait si on
te laisse le prendre c'est tout l'opposé
vont préciser si c'est ça je pense pas
que non mais je pense qu'il ya eu quatre
affaires dont très vite et si c'est fou
prend 1,4 en quatre images in que c'est
plutôt même toit avec les noirs qui peut
enfin tu prétend à rien mais c'est quand
même toi qui as le pion pas ses protégés
et il ya moins de cendre alouettes 4 si
tu t'es des portes pour des 300 hommes
j'appelle été déportés comme ça en gros
dans cette finale là c'est complètement
nul mais c'est maintenant les noirs qui
fin prêt c'est un grand mot mais c'est
plutôt les blancs qui doivent les deux
trois coups précis si je puis me
permettre
merveilleux quatre cavaliers qu'avait
lieu quatre tours d un pour se placer
ces logiques et prend des deux tours en
d2 et nul balle à ses couleurs il faut
toujours posée il ya un battle est sympa
cuisson vous ayez pas rien il y aura
rien
femmes femmes difficile de s'enflammer
pour cette partie en fait depuis
ouais bon sens n'avait pas être pas des
participations depuis le but du tournoi
c'est vraiment bon pour bien trop qu'on
se qualifie en fait on prend aujourd'hui
c'était le pire du pire
désolé les mecs ne pas être forcément
très enjoué ou quoi mais compreniez sais
pas c'est pas facile de d'inventer du
spectacle là où il n'y en a pas assez
vraiment l'équivalent d'un match de foot
on verrait de la passe à dix pendant
pendant 70 minutes
ça me rappelle un match sera belle et
thierry roland et jean micoud qui avait
commenté un truc comme ça il parlait
même plus du match comment non mais vous
faites très bon enfant
c'est rare mais des fois ça arrive en
fin de match 80e qu'entre les deux
équipes sont qualifiées par exemple oui
et je suivais un match comme ça de
monaco en coupe d'europe et très
longtemps vers 97 98 bas et en plus on
peut même pas se rabattre sur une autre
partie qui nous excite rimaison déjà
connues de tous et gnahoré de ses katas
quatre matches de 90 minutes et à quatre
matchs les mecs se font la passe à dix
non mais attention le fort rebond
peut-être les bons mots sortent leur
douche ou lalalalalala levallois passé à
l'immédiat non ils ont fait une passe en
retrait qu'est ce que c'est bien je le
joueur français qui ne prend aucun
risque touche dangereuse à 80 mètres du
but adverse
aucun joueur adverse au pressing
d'ailleurs non mais à la rigueur je
préfère qu'ils signent au nul tout de
suite pas qui quitte à faire ça fait nul
en trois minutes
non mais là encore une heure ça va quand
elle tombe parler un peu faut pas que ça
dure cinq heures on pourrait peut-être
parler du grand prix féminin de monaco
et je crois que ça joue pas encore je
suis vaccarès concept à 15 heures mais
bon on a pas les parties là et puis j'en
veux dire on n'a pas su le ton a depuis
le début bon je peux te faire un petit
résumé
oui mais la série juste de commencer
presque la rose c'est la dernière
j'imagine oui mais je connais depuis
longtemps joué une partie
le coup mais si on fait un point
classement de ce tournoi d'agoria ge qui
naquit en tête avec 7 sur 10 elle peut
être rattrapé encore ou pas bel et bien
en tête parce que derrière les filles
elles sont six
donc elle a besoin d'un nul une nulle
seule gagnante et même en perdant ça se
trouve les autres font pas font pas
gagner parvenir par martinien ces icônes
et rouages qui n'a donc oui me ces
rencontres directes conejo parvenir mais
qu'est ce qu'elle va pas vouloir gérer
comme l'avait fait un bon résultat dans
le premier grand prix j'imagine que l
onu lui convient oui tu joues un peu nul
oui je veux dire par là que garage qui
n'en l est pas camaïeu cas c'est pas une
adversaire direct pour la qualif
donc je peux l'a laissé gagner et
reprendre les pointes oui tu finis
première des autres et très était très
heureuse oui ce nom mais derrière
derrière tu as donc tout à fait 2e
ex-aequo dont kosteniuk et conejo que
c'était new qui joue quoi qu'ils
allaient blanc complète après quatrième
jusqu'à 7e l'on peut être un petit
groupe et aux deux ânes à nous dit shoot
katia maintenant à riga et crying classe
est un groupe important à apprête à
l'auteur musée de choc avec 5 sur 10 50
% puis les joueuses qui ont peu moins
bien aussi leur tournoi à amman dès midi
éric 4 me est ce exact sous le 4 et
vanina au fond avec un point ni sur need
à la finul et de vieillir mais voilà
elles souffrent stand mince sa rage
bafana vivre comme ça car il faut
survivre
- est-ce que tu fais tout raté un ici
tout radio propose nul ou tu prends pour
être gardien sait très bien que
troisième propose neuf la journée je
pense ça arrange aussi maxime qui va
voir un petit peu récupérer encore c'est
à dire
on a là les amis je vais mettre une
petite pub c'est chuck fletcher giggs
c'est dur c'est bien ça cheuvreux autre
chose que l'on verrait vu une pub enfin
il se passe quelque chose je suis
content de ne pas être simple
du coup tu veux être une plus de six
minutes
oui mais il y en avait jusque là
j'arrive pu en mettre j'ai l'impression
quand ils ont ils ont bloqué une minute
allocs et je pense que c'est pas une
mauvaise décision d'ailleurs parce que
c'est bien j'imagine de standards design
minute une minute de pub ça me paraît
être un bon rythme plus ça me paraît
trop donc en réalité je suis assez à des
contents que ce temps pensé longtemps
mais j'écoute le chat est en fusion si
l'on s'attarde le plus pour l'afub je
suis tellement amusée vaincu chambre m
c'est plus une puce pour harvey lettres
du nom il peut il peut il est pas loin
un petit gars ça y est moins forte car
le sel mais on n'a vu l'autre fait de
lacalm battu sur le match après le
problème c'est que la route est très
longue pour y aller et d'autres prétend
déjà vous inscrire aux candidats bon il
est bien il est bien cette fois pour y
aller mais même une fois une fois là-bas
faut encore gagner ce tournoi ce qui est
très dur parce que il ya deux joueurs
qui me semblent bien placés plus
d'expérience ou coup dans ce tournoi
c'est déjà ding et cajon donc déjà
faudra arriver à finir devant eux contre
les autres c'est chaud et voilà après
enfin tu arrives au match on card scène
mais c'est pas une tasse de thé non plus
c'est un tasse de thé se ralliant c'est
pas grave doivent autant c'est vrai car
le sel des plantes est de tel c'est un
joueur d'échecs norvégien rebonds mais
voilà n'ont cessé de parcours est très
long et très dur après maxime tu as
envoyé niro 4 mondial ça manquait pas il
oui s'il donnait un champion du monde ce
sera pas un scandale quoi mais c'est
chaud très chaud
ils ont dit on voit plus karama il se
cache ben non mes cheveux que certains
tournois en fait là il a un appareil
déjà critiquée par les candidats donc il
faut autre chose il y avait joué par
weill hoffman quand même défini pro
hexagonaux oui voilà tu vois quand ils
jouent ça va se débrouiller
il a fait un peu les grandes chaînes ce
tour voilà justin était pas à londres ce
qu'il y'a pas finir et quatre premiers
sinon il serait bien aller et puis on
verra sûrement janvier peut-être avis
can du 10 au 16 août
je sais pas si dans la liste mais ça
pourra être rejointe en a qui pourrait
jouer et s'il joue pas je suis prêt par
les candidats et il n'a pas tort je te
mettre un calendrier surchargé arrivée
sur les genoux ben ouais surtout caruana
il avait joué à
le match en novembre l'année dernière
qui avait dû être assez fatigant bah
ouais et puis moralement et tout ça va
je pense plus qu'à ça pendant un moment
tu te prépares tu te prépares tu te
prépares de ce match qu'ils puissent
tous après faut te faudra battre aussi
mentalement je trouve qu'il s'est très
bien venir d'ailleurs parce que la
défaite était on va pas dire cruel parce
que magnus mérite probablement gagner
mais c'est un match très serré il n'est
pas passé loin de devenir champion du
monde
exact dans un match dans les parties
longues il a vraiment fait jeu égal
contre carlos n ya pas un joueur qui a
plus de vie des autres clairement non
mais son problème c'est ça c'est comment
rapide il est moins fort et de loin et
il a pas réussi à faire la différence en
longues et magnus a superbement maîtrisé
les rapides mais après bon pour caruana
évidemment tu t'es senti que t'es pas si
proche parce que suffit que l'autre
fasse une gaffe ou que tu réussisses à
conclure un peu la seule partie où tu es
mieux du match et tu finis champion du
monde n'était pas loin non de bain c'est
parce qu'il se qualifie il a ses chances
au départ n'est pas largué par un croix
carlson
mais bon mentalement il faut encaisser
ce genre de défaite c'est pas des
défaites qui sont faciles à encaisser et
je trouve que caruana il fait il fait
plutôt une bonne saison c'est le nom de
transition où il a l'objectif des
candidats en mars prochain et il fait
une belle saison clairement mais si vous
parle de mort au hacker semi retraité en
fait depuis un moment mais morrow les
petits jeunes enfin c'est l'âge du thé
topalov ou quoi
j'ai tout candidat et goodrich look moi
je me sens pas gagné après s'il y arrive
je serai content pour lui mais en gris
choo que je vois pas dans quel cas de
figure y gagne en revanche le point
positif pour sacha sais que ce sera à
lui encore le favori du public entre
guillemets sera le chouchou parce que
parce que c'est le mec le plus marrant
dans les conférences de presse et moi
perso c'est mon joueur préféré
en termes de style de jeu de tous
je trouve que c'est celui qui a le plus
beau style afab non mais je joue bien je
joue propre a bien bien préparé et lui
pour la peine dans les partis classiques
il est vraiment la recherche de la
vérité même si tous les mecs je vais
comme grid choc peut-être serait pas
tant que ça contre les parties longues
là c'est juste que maintenant on a une
génération de joueurs qui apprennent
beaucoup de partis ou les mecs cherche
quand même ça a joué dynamique et il
cherche pas la vérité profonde du jeu
c'est pour ça que je vois vraiment plus
l'intérêt des parties longues mais des
mecs comme grille tout que c'est encore
les voir à l'ancienne plus bas il a
l'idée de prépa moderne et ses terrains
mais ils essaient de villemur coup tout
le temps ouais ce qui est pas le cas de
beaucoup de joueurs de haut niveau
non mais des fois juste tu vois une
position claire durand pratique libre
les givet la pression la pendule
mais celle approche moderne qui marche
bien en fait en pratique oui mais ce qui
en fait je fais pas non plus j'aimerais
bien faire ça oui du coup il m'arrive de
perdre est parti comme ça genre celle
contre targaryen l'an dernier la honte
de ce qu'il ya où quoi où ça te rend fou
de perdre une partie par iata perdu tout
seul j'ai perdu 20 kg a joué vite on
sent pas grand chose mais il est libre
oui mais bon j'aime bien ce genre de
joueurs parce que il est encore à la fin
il est encore à la recherche de la
vérité profonde du game non je sais mais
après le truc c'est que c'est moins
efficace mais c'était d'abord gagner en
fait ouais ouais mais ça ça lui ça lui
rend une certaine sympathie non bien sûr
que ça dure plus ils meurent en
conférence de presse son style de jeu
sympa donc le c'est logique ce soit un
jour après sin et joue bien tout court
il joue bien dans sa peau bien joué et
joue bien mieux fou prend 2,4 et vous
encadrez retour pour le 4 ça c'est
surtout revoir dans l'imaginaire 1,8 à
étais tu veux faire 34.4 tourer web ont
passé oui c'est ni plus nombreux vont
monter
peut-être maxime vais essayer de waimes
et quand bien même ceux qui attaquent la
nation pas ses clés noires mais il veut
dire que s'il fait g4 ou des de f4 et
qui met le roi en quatre peut-être que
c'est lui qui fait un truc non mais déjà
bon il a pas joué les photos proposées
donc ça va durer et maxime qui va tenter
j'ai pas envie de dire l'impossible
parce que il essaye de la jouer ça va
pas se retourner contre lui les rangs
gestion un mail me souviens de 502 pas
prendre le risque de pour la perdre oui
oui et je vais rivière bien il gère bien
sa partie il fait pas nous le direct qui
veut un petit peu insister sur la finale
j'ai envie de dire pourquoi pas quand
même un petit peu on va voir on a bon
espoir
bon moi je parie toujours sur nul mais
bon on n'est plus aux morts seront fixés
sur cause noire
je pense c'est plutôt un bon choix
alors
donc tour 8 ça paraît logique prix ça
paraît logique ça paraît logique tourin
ça paraît logique
ça ça paraît quand même ultra logique
pour prendre un aussi prise un airois f7
peut-être je serai bien fou des deux
rois aux six f4 f5 g34 ça t'as pas le
temps peut-être trois f1 voilà dix
croient détroit quelque chose de ce type
là et tu veux mettre le rang 4 et dire
que peut-être qu'un jour ya un zoom gang
way sera l'orateur mais écoute pourquoi
pas toutes simples et épurées sont déjà
met en danger de perdre
c'est toujours agréable une affluence
qui vont s'y joue toujours à
saint-etienne bon on va au club de
saint-etienne pas depuis longtemps mais
mais quoi sinon quand il détourne en
coin et que je suis de passage ou quoi
bien sûr que je peux jouer mais le club
de saint-etienne
un millionnaire il ya une vraie bombe
je peux comprendre mais coûteux on a
essayé de vendre de vendre du rêve de
vente du jeu mais bon on se faisait on
se faisait au toît l'usam web on se
vante à nous-mêmes c'était c'était clair
depuis là on peut se vanter d'avoir plus
ou moins compris le sort de la partie
après sept minutes de jeu
cette position est que on avait on avait
tout de suite on avait tout de suite
anticipé le genre de final on avait
senti que ça donnerait nul il a fallu
attendre une heure vingt pour confirmer
ce sentiment mais la maxime qui a
jouer ce qu'ils avaient à jouer mais je
dirais je donnerai quand même un bon
point andré keane dans le choix de
l'ouverture puisqu'on attendait une
carreaux kanu et 4,5 et du vent il est
allé dans la française en jouant sur sur
le fait que maxime je la veux rentrer
des changes
donc gérer bon très bon choix d'andré
king qui a réussi à feinter comme tu le
disais pour topalov qui a réussi à
changer d'ouverture entre guillemets ne
pas jouer ce qui joue d'habitude et du
cou et du coup d'aller chercher le demi
point
demain on est quand même en dessous je
pense ouais on n'est pas très inquiet
pour maxime demain monnuage unsa encore
une nouvelle au départage du coup oui et
elle a écouté les mecs
merci tout de même d'avoir suivi je
remets quand même une petite pub pour la
sortie
ce n'était pas la journée la plus
excitante on espère demain qui est plus
de spectacle mais au moins j'aurais dit
les poches de pub était sympa quand même
dire ce qu'ils n'ont plus au nord on a
vu toutes les parties femmes ce qui
n'était pas forcément le cas
les autres jours là on a tout on a on
n'a pas raté une miette vous égalez on
s'est régalé en amont n'a pas laissé une
seule partie on a toute analyse à fond
belles heures de jeu et n'existait pas à
flots la chaîne si vous êtes plus votre
mii et à 300 en traçant 4 880 personnes
qui soulèvera le trophée
oui bonsoir nos besoins vos mouvements
ouais la partie en solo dix ans passés à
la fin c'était un peu longuet soyons en
soyons sérieux
mais bon j'imagine que j'espère que les
gens nous ne nous tiennent pas rigueur
femmes
je crois qu'on n'est pas trop
responsables comme rennes on peut on
peut on peut d parfois un peu en
rajouter et être un peu dans le dans
l'excès mais la faig 35 1340 et ont
souvent que les autres partis rapidement
mais en fait elles sont déjà toutes fini
par l'annuaire est bien la plus apte à
celle de karine et les autres seuil en
est une qu'il est fan on peut te montrer
salaire en entier tient montre avons
tout cas rien qui nous est dit quand
même
après entre montre un sonnet ponia che
ck une belle partie sa femme pam g5 dont
g8 et c4
c'est fun et à celle là oui c'était la
plus belle
c'était une petite brune fall femmes
ouais c'est la vente at on a pu y croire
on a un moment parce que vous êtes les
seuls achats d'options les uns après les
autres
mais non l'abonné gainey vous êtes
responsable mais pas coupable
bon ça va si tu es tu vois la réf bah
ouais les inconnus
tu vois le tu vois le sketch des
inconnus ou pas ouais mais c'est une
phrase on entend souvent
weezy jarre en ce qui concerne ce qui
concerne la vente de drogue je sais pas
quoi vous étiez au courant
il veut pas répondre à aller lâché une
info j'étais en courant
responsable mais pas coupable bon voilà
nulle part 17 les blancs organise à cet
échange est pas le truc tu auras trois
pions sur les mails nul et puis
iakovenko navarin le choc de la journée
et bayod nul aussi une belle sortie de
la théorie aura pas leur fermer sortie
de la théorie nuls direct après donc là
il ya vraiment pas dire est le seul qui
as qui a tenté un tout petit truc c'est
voici les sauts les autres c'est ont
fini on sort de la théorie nuls direct
pour les mecs vont même au slap chop up
saw this way bref bon bref on se sert
prix de familles soit je savais pas
c'est pas mon époque pour moi c'était le
sketch pour moi c'est le désert gold
phase du conflit
il s'inspire de faits réels souvent way
un message imaginez pas que ça puisse
être responsable mais pas coupable
bon c'est de ma faute mais non plus
extraordinaire bon sur ce fameux sur ces
belles paroles
on se retrouve demain à partir de 14h en
espérant un peu plus de spectacle
bon sûrement merci ciao ciao